now today we have a wonderful
opportunity to look at birds in a new
way and our guide is dr. Richard Prum
he's an ornithologist can you say that
ornithologist ornithologist that is a
person who studies birds now dr. prohm
is a professor of Ornithology ecology
and evolutionary biology here at yale
yale and his specialty is looking at the
study of feather growth and their
coloration and today he's going to share
his thoughts on the evolution of birds
particularly why birds are dinosaurs so
perhaps you'll welcome a professor from
with me to the podium okay well thank
you for coming this morning can
everybody hear me
yeah great I'm going to introduce or
start today by introducing myself I am
basically a bird watcher I started as a
bird watcher at about the age of 10 and
it was about six months after I got my
first pair of glasses and I think I was
sort of a regular scientific kid looking
around the world for something to attach
my curiosity to something that would be
fascinating and I got a pair of glasses
and suddenly the world came into focus
and the objects of my future obsessions
appeared in the environment in focus and
I think since that time I have just
continued wander down the same path as
essentially a scientific bird watcher
what's been most fascinating to me is
the diversity of birds all the different
kinds and luckily for me that's been an
excuse to travel anywhere in the world
where just about anywhere you're going
to find some fascinating birds so it's
been it's been a marvelous career in
science about 20 years after I started
bird-watching though when I was already
professional and a professor I came to
realize something that was amazing it
wasn't amazing in a little way like the
little discoveries we make during a
scientific research or career but it was
in May
in a big way and what was amazing was to
realize
finally the strength through the
strength of the evidence and the end the
rigour of the analysis that living birds
are actually extent dinosaurs and that
just about every aspect of the biology
of birds that we're interested in can be
changed or informed by our understanding
of this this new and exciting fact come
on in guys there's plenty of chairs and
chairs even down front so what I want to
do today is share that that excitement
and tell you a little bit about about
the biology of dinosaurs the biology of
birds and why we know that birds are
dinosaurs
so the talk today a better more cheeky
title and one that I thought that I
should send but I didn't is is why
should we care about the dinosaur origin
of birds and I guess I was afraid that
too many people answer well I don't and
not show up so I didn't use this title
but it's really the tie it is the real
title of what I'm going to talk about
today why should we care and I hope that
by the end of the day I'll convince you
that there's a lot of amazing things
both about our understanding of birds
themselves and are trying to imagine and
understand the biology of dinosaurs that
would change by the by the fact that
birds have originated as a lineage of
dinosaurs so when the today's talk what
we'll do is cover three things first
evidence that birds are theropod
dinosaurs that they are evolved from a
particular group of dinosaurs the
theropods the bipedal meat-eating
dinosaurs and then how theropod how the
theropod origin of birds changes our
view of bird biology and then lastly how
the theropod origin of birds changes our
view of dinosaur biology and that'll be
our trip so we're going to dive right in
and now with today's with the size of
today's group I'm going to ask what we
wait for questions toward the end and I
will promise or commit to be here as
long as the last questioner wants or
until we get kicked out of the room bye
bye bye someone okay so how do we know
that birds are theropod dinosaurs well
this is an example in science of a
historical question
right and I'm going to introduce you
right off the bat to the fact that we
are trying to reconstruct a little bit
about the history of the Tree of Life if
you imagine the ancestry of all the
organisms on the planet they are
interrelated to one another through
history and the history forms a tree in
this tree of life is one of the primary
goals of the historical science of
biology the kind of questions we asked
in historical science are a little
different than our you may be familiar
with in other aspects of biology classes
or other other science classes actually
we're going to be interested in
questions that are more related maybe to
cosmology the history of the universe
than some other questions right and our
seyh linguistics we're trying to
reconstruct what was happening in the
past now in order to do this we're going
to be using the field of systematics and
evolutionary biology and this is the
expertise of people here at Yale that
you'll find in the Peabody Museum or the
department of ecology and evolutionary
biology well how do we reconstruct the
The Tree of Life well the way we do it
is looking for particular kinds of
characters and these characters what we
called shared derived characters and
they help us identify branches in the
Tree of Life
well what is a shared derived character
well shared we all understand those are
characters that more than one organism
has and derived Meads novel or new
they've evolutionarily new and these so
traits that are evolutionary new and
shared are the ones they're going to
help us examine a branch there's a
thought experiment so let's imagine
whether we we're looking at a lung fish
I don't even need a picture of it you
can all imagine right it's a big lumpy
looking fish and it actually has lungs
and you guys have question well is it
closer to fish like a salmon or a trout
or is it closer to a cow right or
perhaps a human being well there's lots
of characters that the lung fish shares
with other fish scale leanness and
swimming in the water etc but there's
one special character a shared derived
character that says with other other
tetrapods including us and that's the
presence of lungs so the the presence of
a shared derived characters help us
identify the
inches in the tree of life and one of
those branches would be a branch that
includes the ANSYS or the descendants of
those organisms that evolved lungs in
particular things like the lungfish and
ourselves so we're going to be examining
shared derived characters to reconstruct
the history of life and in order to do
is what we what we need to do is examine
extant birds their characters fossil
Birds other fossil dinosaurs other
reptiles for shared derived features so
in the first part of the doc now I'm
going to be introducing you to some of
that evidence
this is Archaeopteryx lithographic a--
the the the famous fossil bird this is
the earliest extol our it is immune
Aversa lee agrees is a is a nice clothes
most closely related to birds
it's a has feathers and all these other
features and it was certainly discovered
excitingly two years after the
publication of the Origin of Species and
led to some new appreciation for it the
evolutionary theory and the origin of
birds however the origin of birds and
particularly relationships of
Archaeopteryx were controversial from
the beginning if we look it actually has
a mosaic of characters including a bunch
of avian similarity similarities with
with birds including feathers
wings that were shaped as four limbs a
furcula
the Furcal is the fuse clavicles that's
the wishbone that everybody knows from
the barbaric Thanksgiving ritual it
extends luck to those who who grab the
victims who get the big side right the
furcula
which a little bone in the in the in the
in the chest the pubis which is a bone
in the in the in the sin sacrum or in
the pelvis that points backward
partially fused foot bones and the first
toe are hallux pointing backwards these
are all features that tell us that
Archaeopteryx is a closely related to
birds now there were other ones that
were more reptilian similarities
presence of teeth a long bony tail on
jointed ribs gastrula or belly ribs you
can see right here
no sternum in some cases no carpo
metacarpus this is a complex bone that
you everyone will recognize the next
time they have buffalo wings from the
hand and then claws on the fingers which
were also
reptilian so what scientists needed to
do all
to Italy was to to look among these and
try to figure out which of these are
derived in which of these are or
perimeter or not derived similarities in
order to reconstruct the tree well
there's been a lot of controversy and
I'm going to skip over the history we
could talk about it's been very colorful
and and fascinating but what I what I'm
going to skip right to is the is is to
the punchline what is the history or
what is the the The Tree of Life this
particular branch of the Tree of Life
look like now based on the evidence we
have now well the critical break in this
in this century long story came with the
discovery of Deinonychus and this was
described in the 60s and 70s by John
Ostrom
who's a curator at the Yale Peabody
Museum and a professor in geology and
geophysics and he described Deinonychus
this Raptor dinosaur from a specimen
that was from the American West that was
about 80 million years old and in in
over the ensuing years in combination
with Jacques Gautier who's now also a
professor here at Yale and in the
Peabody Museum a new hypothesis was
established based on the identification
of shared derived similarities from the
tip of the of the nose all the way to
the tip of the tail every part of the of
the body to support the idea that these
Raptor dinosaurs in particular we're
very closely related to birds now this
is Bambi Raptor the most recent Raptor
or one of the most recent Raptor
dinosaurs described from the American
West what we're going to do is march
through the body and and review some of
these characters to give you a
background we'll start with what the
Tree of Life looks like so here's an
example of a tree so imagine these
branches are lineages in the Tree of
Life and these ancient events give rise
to new groups this we're starting with
at the further back in the tree this is
tetrapods this is the phylogeny of all
the creatures that have four limbs so
here's our tetrapod ancestor and the
first branch to branch offering
amphibians like frogs and and and
salamanders next come to mammals which
include us and then this branch we call
reptiles includes turtles lizards and
snakes and other odd things like to
atera and then this grape here is where
we're going to be for the rest of today
these are the arcus oars and the arcus
oars are a branch of
tiles that includes crocodilians
pterosaurs and the branch that gave rise
to birds and dinosaurs this is our
little neighborhood and we all go
through the characters that support this
we'll go right into the birds and
dinosaurs here now the Tree of Life is
complicated and all of you probably know
more some of you probably know more
dinosaurs than I do but the tree of life
of dinosaurs look something like this
well every way back in the past we had a
single lineage and through a series of
speciation events we ended up with this
large radiation of dinosaurs through
time well let's look at the main
branches the first branch we have are
the ornithischian dinosaurs over here
and the sole Richie and dinosaurs over
here let's look at the ornithischians
well we got ceratopsians iguanodons is
Hydra swords what are those names and I
think most of you know the ornithischian
dinosaurs pretty well they're a bunch of
mostly vegetarian and mostly walking on
four legs dinosaurs what some with
ornamentation like horns and as I'm sure
all of you are excited about the
Torosaurus sculpture one of the
ceratopsians going up this little uh
that weren't all large here's the I
think micros era tops which is about the
size of a modern rabbit and some were
highly armored so those are the
ornithischians vegetarians now in the
survey she and dinosaurs this is a large
group that includes all of the theropods
and the birds here's birds right up at
the top the tiny of this branch one
little branch written within this larger
radiation well this first branch here
back here give rise to the sauropods
what were they they're the closest to
this theropod group we're going to be
talking about the sauropods of course
were the gigantic vegetarian dinosaurs
including brontosaurus back
Brachiosaurus seismosaurus these huge
things the next group of course is this
theropods and these are the meat-eating
bipedal dinosaurs this branch right here
that includes birds we're going to be
spending a few minutes looking at those
that those groups and trying to find out
why birds belong within them here's our
well known theropods things like
Allosaurus or our friend Tyrannosaurus
Rex over Raptor there's a big list guy
or toothless guy with a beak and
velociraptor this is the thing that
chased their kids around the kid
in Jurassic Park right and what we'll
find is that a velociraptor look sad it
looked a whole lot different than it did
in the in the Jurassic Park movie well
in my ornithology class to Yale
undergrads what we do is we march to
this tree and learn all these learn all
these characters but in each case here
what I've shown is a particular little
branch I've labeled with a bunch of
shared derived characters these are the
anatomical or features that allow us to
identify who is who and what branch the
birds belong to what I'm going to do is
give you a quick pass through this tree
and and show you some of the of the
features that support it one of the
things that's fascinating is to
understand the or many of the characters
that are most understandable are those
that contribute to how creatures
function and so I want to talk a little
bit is about how crocodiles walk so if
you imagine you can imagine crocodile
walking like this he's walking along and
in order he his body is swiveling in the
middle and he's using his tail as he
walks well why is he using his tail as
he walks well in order to make the femur
or this bone in the in the in the leg
pulled backwards he has large set of
muscles and these muscles actually
attach on the tail so one of the
functions is the tail in a crocodile is
to help pull that leg backwards as you
as he walks he has a huge muscle this
caught ephemerality on us that does that
and that muscle attaches to a bump on
the femur
that's this leg bone that allows that
muscle to pull really hard on that on
that leg and that allows crocodiles to
walk now this is informative because
crocodiles are the living reptiles that
are closest to birds let's see what the
situation is in birds well in birds this
caught ephemerality is really kind of
tiny it's a little strapped shape and it
doesn't really contribute much to the to
how birds walk it's actually a little
bit like like the appendix it's kind of
a vestigial muscle now if we look
throughout dinosaur and and that
theropod phylogeny what we find is as we
go from crocodiles through
ornithischians sauropods and then to the
theropods what we see is a reduction in
the size of the tail and the size of the
changes that this muscle inserts on so
it's getting smaller and smaller through
evolutionary time after bipedal
bipedality evolved the next detail got
smaller and if we look at the bump on
the on the femur that the muscle inserts
on we find that it gets smaller and
smaller smaller it's very small or not
existed in Deinonychus and almost
non-existent in living birds so that's
an example of an evolutionary trend
derived features that support the
placement of birds and dinosaurs moving
up the body if we look at the at the
pelvis we see all sorts of features that
are associated with the origin of birds
in particular one of the the pubis this
bone within the within the pelvis that
points backwards this feature is found
earlier on in Raptor dinosaurs and then
in editors including Tyrannosaurus and
within all these theropods so we can see
this trend to the evolution of a bipedal
bipedal sin sacrum or pelvis in the
evolution of these Birds
here's Deinonychus and other Raptors now
moving up the body from the if we look
at the hind limb we see all sorts of
features one is the hind toe pointing
backwards almost in a perched position
of course the Raptor dinosaurs had the
killer claw the killer second claw and
even if we look closely at Archaeopteryx
fossil you'll find wait a minute that
first toe is a little bigger than we'd
expect there's some elements of that
enlarged first row that we find in
Archaeopteryx we also see some the way
the leg bones are attached the way the
axial skeleton moves even within the
chest cavity one of the things that's
interesting some of you may know that
birds have air sacs that a lot of their
there have out pocketing zuv the lungs
that invade many of the bones of the
skeleton and the head they're not used
for breathing but they do hold air and
the interesting thing is that if we go
back into theropod dinosaurs we find
that a lot of their bones are hollow in
the same way that bird bones are that
this evolved long before bird flight but
it's another feature that you that
unites them if we look in more detail at
the hand or at the at the at the chest
cavity we'll see that for example here's
the fertility which bone of Bambi Raptor
it turns out that the wishbone is not a
unique feature in birds but evolved
earlier on in the theropod dinosaurs and
if anyone's had the opportunity to see
sue at in Chicago at the Field Museum
one of the great best discoveries that
was found with sue this new
Tyrannosaurus Rex it's on exhibit there
is that it turns out it has a fur Killa
it has a wishbone
so Tremaine asaurus rex even had a
wishbone that would have been a heck of
a Thanksgiving ritual I think there
would have been a lot of arguments over
who won that I think they would have
been able to pull it apart so so the fur
Killa this bone and this bone actually
it's almost identical to the furcula of
Archaeopteryx within the wing bones this
is the humerus that or the arm bones
within the humerus of the of the of the
forelimb there's a curvature in some of
them that that are shared only by Birds
etc so when we look at the at the at the
bodies the characters a baby Raptor or
theropod dinosaurs and Archaeopteryx
what we see if the whole host of
features going throughout the body that
unites them share derived features that
indicate that Birds the appropriate
position for birds within the Tree of
Life is within the theropod dinosaurs
this informs a lot of interesting things
for example my colleague Gautier has
been able to show pretty convincingly
that the that the prey capture stroke
within Raptor dinosaurs that ability to
run out and seize say small children in
the kitchen or whatever whatever prey
item with your four limbs and bring them
in and sort of praying mantis-like
stroke preceded the evolution of the
flight stroke in Birds which is an
amazingly similar item and so there this
is an example of features that have that
come at it oh another another one that's
great is the fingers birds have three
digits within the hand and if we look at
a phylogeny going from crocodiles
ornithischian dinosaurs sauropods up to
the theropod dinosaurs what we see is a
reduction of the outer digits these are
their hand right here what we see is
that the Pinky and the ring finger
become gradually reduced until finally
they're lost within Allosaurus and then
and then Deinonychus and Archaeopteryx
and this is some of the most amazing
characters here we have the feathers are
the hands of a modern bird and
Archaeopteryx and Deinonychus and one of
the fascinating things this is one of
the things that really sold me was that
you
within the third finger a long bone then
two short bones and then a long bone and
that's in Deinonychus and here's an
Archaeopteryx a long bone two short
bones and a long bone why does that
happen that's what when the hand closes
those those that third finger actually
closes in on the hand instead of folding
straight down folds in at an angle to
close in around a piece of food or prey
item well some of the most exciting
evidence though came not from the bones
which are the classic materials of
paleontology but from a new realm and
that was the presence of feathers
starting in about 1998 with some
exciting finds from Liaoning Province in
China there were a basically a new
treasure trove of fossils discovering
for the first time filamentous or fuzzy
materials on the skin of theropod
dinosaurs these fossils were about 125
million years old and they included a
diversity of creatures well one of the
problems with them is that well some of
the the first Chinese researchers that
described them said these are primitive
feathers these are the first feathers
and the feathers originated in dinosaurs
before the origin of flight and before
the origin of birds this is a very
threatening hypothesis and the reason is
that for about a hundred years the
favorite idea for how feathers came to
be was that they evolved as as elongate
scales for the purpose of flight and
that basically feathers evolved for
flight from from things that looked a
lot like shingles on a house just
imagine a scale getting longer and
longer and longer so when people looked
at this fuzzy stuff they said that can't
be feathers that can't be simple
feathers or primitive feathers because
feathers evolved for flight and that
wouldn't work for flight at all right so
what happened in the literature about
five years ago there was a problem in
determining well what did primitive
feathers look like the problem was that
Archaeopteryx of course has completely
modern feathers so to understand the
origin of feathers we had to imagine
backwards into the evolutionary past to
try to reconstruct what they look like
and this is some of the subject of my
own research to give you a little
background I'll show you how we try to
solve this problem here
a feather feathers are complicated
branch structures they're the most
complicated things that grow out of the
skin of just about any animal and
they're they have the main shaft or Akos
and then coming off the shaft or a
series of smaller branches called Barb's
and if we look at those Barb's here's an
example of a barb coming off the of the
of the main shaft of the feather
there are even smaller branches coming
off of those Barb's these are called
barbules the feather flies or allows
flight because there are tiny little
hooks on the tips of the barbules that
hook into the into the grooves of the
barbules of the neighboring barb and all
these like velcro they zipper the
feather together and this is a you know
a both an engineering feat and a and an
evolutionary feat how do these
complicated branch structures
evolve well just to give you more
background it's all sorts of different
kinds of feathers like the the down
that's in your pillow or feathers on the
on the on the body of birds they vary in
the shape of these little barbules and
determine whether it's fuzzy or in a
plane here's an example of a fuzzy down
feather well how do these things all
grow well one of the things I hope you
all remember is that the key to this
mystery comes in the fact that feathers
are totally tubular and this is
shameless co-option of surfer slang to
mean really cool but it also like the
ultimate way that you might surf on but
also the tubular arity of feathers is
one of the key features that allows us
to understand how fed to diversity
happen and this is an example of a of a
embryonic chick and it shows that the
feathers before they come out all fluffy
they actually are completely tubular if
we cut a growing feather in half like
this here's from a growing contour
feather from Omaha you'll see that it's
arranged in a tube
there's dermal pulp in the middle and
that this the feather is actually this
tubular material that's hollow and that
these are the barb bridges these are the
things that are going to become the the
branches of the feather if we look at it
in cross-section we see it's rolled up
in a tube and all those specialized
branches are these are these these
features on the side
all rolled up why how does that turn
into a branched feather
well feathers are pretty amazing in that
they're branched like a tree but they
grow from their base like a hair and
what that means is we think about how a
tree branches it branches by bifurcation
or branching at each of each of its tips
but if in a feather the tip so the
feather is the oldest well the answer to
that is it is it is a unique form of
growth that we call helical growth and
here's a cartoon version of it and when
I first started lecturing on this I
would get you know lots of chalk and I
get all you know confused looks at the
audience so take me weeks but then we
designed this this this computer
animation for about to see is a quick
computer animation of the process of
branched feather growth to get the idea
of how a branched feather grows from a
within the embryo so it starts as a
small tube this is our a little
outgrowth of the of the skin it's hollow
in the center and that tube becomes
subdivided into a series of compartments
each of these compartments are going to
be the barbs of the feather and they
grow by actually by recruitment of stem
cell progeny out of the bottom at the
bottom of this tube is a series of stem
cells that grow all the cells that
become the fetter now it's being pushed
out of the follicle or this tube on the
ventral side we have new Barbara jizz
growing and you can see they're not
growing straight down they're actually
growing with a bias toward the dorsal
side they're growing there they're
growing around as they get longer as
they go toward the dorsal side what
happens is they crash into one another
and fuse alright and so then when they
fuse they're actually forming the shaft
of the rakers of the feather then when
the growth is done that sheep falls off
and they opens up and as it opens up it
forms the planer feather that we know so
this shows that the inside of the
feather the bottom surface of the
feather comes from the inside of the
tube and the top surface of the feather
comes from the outside of the tube and
that's one of the things that showed
that the feathers couldn't evolve as
elongate scales they because the top and
bottom surfaces are not that are not the
same ones so so what I ended up doing
was was
it was creating a theory for the
evolution of feathers based on how they
grew and I started and this is the whole
you know the whole ball of wax right
here we're going to go take it quickly
and simply through a series of stages
and what I imagined is this is a little
cartoon imagine that little tube that
circle at the bottom of the tube as it
grows this is a cartoon version of how
it grew and I imagine that the simplest
feather was the simplest possible tube
this undifferentiated collar that and
that the next stage was the
compartmentalization of that into
something that would grow different bar
bridges and then helical growth of the
bar bridges or or the evolution of
barbules those little that the secondary
little branches both of them together
and then and then differentiated
barbules what did that look like in
terms of the feathers well each one of
these follicles will actually make it a
specific kind of feather well what did
the simplest feather look like well we
predicted that the simplest feather
would be a tube a simple tube right and
that the second stage of feathers would
be a tuft and then finally either a
planar feather or a complicated tuft and
then finally a doubly branched feather
but notice there's no hooks to for them
to hook on to the neighbor only at that
point
could you get hooks to develop or evolve
those are here there's little distal
hooks on the barbules that hook onto the
neighbors so this is the first feather
that would that would form a coherent
vein or tight vein and then finally an
asymmetrical feather like this one that
evolves in flight and other graduate
level subjects in feather diversity so
um so here's that here's a scenario for
how feathers went from simple to
complicated and one of the interesting
things about this theory is that shows
that this is the first feather that
could have functioned in flight so the
punchline here is that saying that
feathers evolved for flight is like
saying that fingers evolved to play the
piano
right which is a course of silly idea
and why is that well because only the
most derived and specialized possible
fingers or digits could could function
in such a specialized way to produce the
kind of movements that are required to
play piano in the same way only the most
complicated and derived feathers could
have had a coherent tight vein
would have functioned in flight well how
are we able to test this model well
luckily there was a whole explosion of
fossils coming out of China literally
many many new fossils each year with
amazing new features here was this one
sign onethis Sinosauropteryx with with
the the simplest form of Dino fuzz
single filaments probably hollow then
came caught dipteryx which was on
display at the Yale Peabody back in 1999
and and and here's a organism called
sine run at the source this is a raptor
dinosaur at this point in about the year
2000 they were already still lots of
skeptics on this and we were able to
examine this this piece of sort of
Cretaceous roadkill if you will this is
a Raptor dinosaur about the size of a
fox but you can see that is covered with
this this fuzzy stuff all around its
skin and by examining this a great
detail we were able to find out that it
had feathers that were very much like
stage 2 and stage 3 of the model but the
final piece of evidence came from this
guy this is on a dromaeosaurus or from
China and these are impressions
there's the Reyes the main shaft and
here the barbs coming off so this was
absolutely perfect evidence of modern
feathers on a dinosaur that had the
killer claw on its foot just like a
Deinonychus and much closer in age to -
to the origin of birds so so these were
now great evidence that feathers evolved
in Don pteropod dinosaurs before the
origin birds and before the origin of
flight so if we look at this example of
the of the tree of theropods here are
birds up here and there's Archaeopteryx
the sister the closest branch to
Archaeopteryx includes the Raptor
dinosaurs and true a daunted than others
caudipteryx and Oviraptor Tyrannosaurus
this diverse group here and then
ultimately Allosaurus or the large other
large meat-eaters so let's look at the
distribution of these feathers on the
tree the simplest feather was found in
Sinosauropteryx then the tufted Venters
found in bepi asaurus this there
xena sore complete modern feathers with
a vein and everything in caudipteryx
also in all the Raptor dinosaurs and
then within the birds of course
asymmetrical feathers the kind of
feathers that would allow birds to fly
asymmetrical in shape like the like the
wing on an airplane and so if we examine
the the pattern of these shared derived
features what we can see is that the
origin of feathers occurred very likely
in this branch of theropod dinosaurs and
very likely with a very simplest tubular
feather then then we can see that all of
these share another level of complexity
reflected by stage to that stage to some
kind of tufted feather evolved back here
then we don't have sufficient fossils to
nail down exactly all these other stages
but a complicated feather evolving
somewhere in these lineages certainly by
here and then lastly the asymmetrical
feather the flight feather in the in the
birds well this was an amazing amount of
progress in under five years we had gone
from knowing almost nothing about the
origin of feathers to having a detailed
hypothesis about how feather complexity
evolved and it showed that that feathers
were no longer unique to birds that the
thing that had been thought since the
time of Aristotle and Lee and the
ancient Greeks to be something
absolutely unique to birds was actually
not unique to birds but found in in in
theropod dinosaurs before the origin of
the group that we call birds we were
able to confirm this with some molecular
studies of how feathers grow and I'm not
going to spend much time in it except to
say that there's possible to unite
paleontological studies with modern
molecular biology and look at some of
the aspects so we were able to look at
the development of feathers using
studies of the expression of the genes
sonic hedgehog yes that that was named
after the character in the Nintendo game
and bone morphogenic protein which as
far as I know it is not the name of a
character in any computer game but by
studying these genes were able to also
confirm some of the aspects of the model
well this is fascinating because after
you know literally thousands of years to
think that feathers were unique to birds
we found out the feathers are not unique
to birds they evolved in theropod
dinosaurs and it's one of the first
thing
that came as a real shock to to to
ornithologists I think is we have our
own special word ornithology a name to
call ourselves and we like to think that
many of the things that our attributes
are birds are really special and by
finding out that they evolved in earlier
on we find that they're maybe maybe
they're less special than we thought
and this has overturned a lot of what we
thought well there's been even more
exciting discoveries what came after
this was Microraptor
Microraptor GUI is a is a small dinosaur
if this this fossil would be about this
big the body is a little bit bigger than
a pigeon with this long tail about 28 24
inches long but what's fascinating about
it is that it has asymmetrical feathers
on its wings on its four limbs and on
its hind limbs and if you see right here
you can see that it also has even for a
raptor of this size a killer claw at
second toe this long tail and in a
paddle shaped sort of teardrop shaped
paddle of feathers at the end of the
tail this was a revolution because it
appears to be a four winged dinosaur and
it's actually in the this and many other
internal characters place it in the
Raptor dinosaurs not with the birds so
it overturned a lot of what we thought
we knew about feathers and the evolution
of flight here's our previous hypothesis
with asymmetrical feathers originating
in the ancestor birds and absent in
Microraptor and and the dromaeosaurus
but this indicated that actually
asymmetrical feathers originated before
the origin of the group we call birds
right so now even even flight even
aerodynamic behavior the thing that we
really thought was was unique to Birds
may not be unique to the group that
people have traditionally called birds
so suddenly flight and feathers the
things that in generations of
Ornithology classes people said this is
what makes a bird are now no longer
restricted to birds what does that mean
well it means that at least in some
intellectual level we have a crisis what
do we call birds you know how do we
distinguish birds from dinosaurs and the
interesting thing is that this problem
is a result of advanced and and a new
discovery it's a result of our knowledge
not
and our previous certainty that feathers
and flight were restricted to birds was
a result of our ignorance of the Tree of
Life and the pattern of character
evolution now I want to point to oh
there's one more fascinating wrinkle
about Microraptor these guys think that
it's possible that the two wings of
birds in this group may have evolved
from four wings originally it within
Microraptor and that the this that
gliding on four wings may be primitive
to the to the to the to the
dromaeosaurus and intrude on Ted's when
that this four wings may have evolved to
- this may be similar to the way we see
in insects where primitively insects
like dragonflies or butterflies have
four wings but some lots of specialized
groups of insects have only two like
like flies so that's an exciting new
frontier in the indian research what
about this one I want to point to
another thing and this is our old
favorite pal Tyrannosaurus the first
thing I want to say is that it's at the
Tree of Life now tells us or or
supported triolet that Tyrannosaurus is
unrelated to the other large meat-eaters
it's an independent origin of huge
ferocious carnivorous theropod right
which is kind of what kind of neat it
was a great idea invented multiple times
like a you know of cereal movie just
kept coming out you know you know
vicious predator number two you know and
and and but but as you can see here it's
sitting right within the the picture the
part of the Tree of Life that would tell
us that man t-rex had feathers right and
when I when I can remember I came to
visit when I was not yet here at Yale I
came to visit at a meeting for John
Ostrom here at Yale in 1999 where all
the caudipteryx and Sinosauropteryx all
these guys were but we were just putting
together this story and how it might
happen and and I was electrifying I went
back and I put my kids I lined him up
literally on the couch
you know and I said listen guys I want
you to remember this I want you I'm
going to tell you Tyrannosaurus Rex had
feathers and I want you to remember that
I told you right because you're the
first kids on the block
let notice right I you la are now 90 Rex
adapt that if there's no way you know
but one of the things we predict from
this phylogeny from this tree is that
it's a
Rex its ancestors had feathers right
that it's embedded within the tree so if
we found a fossil Buffalo and we asked
ourselves the question now did this
Buffalo have hair or not of course we
would say yes right because by its
position on the tree all of its
relatives have Buffalo even if the
fossil bones themselves don't show
evidence of hair right so from on this
basis Allen brush and I and a few others
as well
predicted that the Tyrannosaurus Rex
should have feathers now I talked about
this is a historical science we don't
often get chances to make predictions
and test them in the same way that
biology or that other BOTS scientists
might do you can go out and look at the
demonstrations on different materials
and you'll be able to test hypotheses in
a matter of you know minutes right well
evolutionary biologists who look in
ancient history don't have a chance to
do that but luckily we made this
prediction and then thanks to the
Liaoning fauna in last year or this
earlier this year in in March they had
the description of D long paradoxes by
jiuxiang and colleagues at in Beijing
this was the the earliest fossil
Tyrannosaurus relative again from the
Leone of China about 125 million years
old
here's an images of its skull here's a
reconstruction of its body it was about
a 8 feet long and about a 4 feet high
and when you look at its bones in detail
what you see is that it has filamentous
materials growing off of its tail that
are basically identical in morphology to
many of the fossil theropod feathers
that we've seen and so from this we can
conclude that yes the relatives of t-rex
had feathers now was t-rex itself
covered with feathers well you know we
don't know there's a lot of reasons to
think that feathers might have been less
useful in an animal with a large body
size so for example if we think of an
elephant modern elephants have lost most
of their hair or reduced hair right
because they don't they don't need that
much hair to stay warm right and so
t-rex itself might have been kind of
like a modern elephant but if you look
at an elephant's ears you know there's
hair in there right it is air hair at
the end of its of its tail and so I
would I would be convinced that I would
still make the bold prediction
if we ever find fossils that
Tyrannosaurus Rex indeed had some kind
of feathers on its body
maybe the chicks in the nest were fuzzy
like like like bird chicks are okay well
that's a summary of the evidence of why
we know the verge of theropod dinosaurs
what I want to do now is talk about how
the theropod original bird changes our
view of bird biology we're going to
focus on a few questions in bird biology
here so what what do we do first well
for a lot of duck Birds it may be pretty
simple to imagine them as dinosaurs
here's a cassowary a cassowary is a
flightless bird from Australia New
Guinean and as far as I'm concerned
except for the fact that it doesn't have
teeth this would be just about as
vicious as as any as any of you know
Raptor you could imagine and indeed
actually although it's convergent this
guy has a big claw on the second toe and
it's about the only bird that's known to
kill people
it actually can kick you in the stomach
and you know give you a leap of loath
with one of its toes right so though it
has he sort of converged on some of the
interesting interesting this weird thing
it turns out these guys communicate in
infrasound very low-frequency sound
right like elephants do and the latest
hypothesis for the function of this this
weird crest on the head is that that may
be a sort of like a radiating device
like the like the melon on a whale for
for for disseminating this this sound
now other birds are kind of hard to
imagine as as as dinosaurs right this
being this is among the smallest the
hovering or flying hummingbirds which
are found in the new world and mostly in
South America well it turns out that
there's lots of features of a bird
biology that we can understand better by
looking at dinosaurs this is an amazing
sign a find from Mongolia this is a nest
of Oviraptor this is a large bipedal
theropod closely related to birds and
indeed you can see this individual is
this is the leg bones here the two arm
bones there's part of the skull there's
the there's the the breast of the
that's been eroded away what we have
here is just the individual sitting on
top of the eggs so this is an example of
a fossilized nesting behavior so the
individual is actually sitting on top of
his or her eggs protecting them either
keeping them warm perhaps we don't know
if they actually bruited them the way a
modern bird does but at least protecting
the eggs physically and we now know that
Oviraptor is a bird or is a dinosaur
that had feathers and so you see this
gap between the arm and the body and
it's very likely that there were
feathers all along here to help to
protect the eggs so one of the most
distinct attributes of birds is the fact
that they sit on their eggs to incubate
is something that again evolved in
theropod dinosaurs before the origin of
birds but there's more birds have a
unique way of laying eggs
well Fischer on male birds have two
testes but female birds have only one
ovary the left ovary and here's the
ovary and this is the long tube down
which the egg is produced and then the
shell gland before the egg is laid so it
turns out that birds produced a clutch
of eggs with that one ovary while they
differ from most reptiles imagine the
sea turtle you've all seen movies of sea
turtles that come up on the beach they
lay all their eggs at once right in one
big clunk and it turns out that many
most dinosaurs did as well sauropods
certainly crocodiles do that's the way
that reptiles compose a clutch by laying
our eggs all at one time but birds in
contrast lay their eggs one a day so
they complete the clutch through a
series of days this is what we call
serial composition of the clutch and its
unique to Birds no other reptiles do it
and for years this has thought to be an
adaptation for for flight if you only
lay one egg a day instead of you know
keeping 10 or 15 eggs and laying them
all at once that means you can stay nice
and light and fly so it made sense that
this had evolved as a result of an
adaptation to flight but one of the
fascinating things if we look back again
at the eggs of theropod dinosaurs is
that they lay there laid in pairs this
is an example of a Troodon nest a
picture care of Dave Riccio at Montana
State and what you can see if you
examine these
Aixa detail you'll see that they're laid
in pairs right and that implied that
they weren't all laid at the same time
it wasn't the whole clutch of twenty
five or twenty four thirty eggs wasn't
laid at ones that were composed over a
series of times what's the possibility
that they could have been laid two at a
time well huh so so this this this
evidence imply that well perhaps
theropod dinosaurs compose the clutch in
a serial fashion - then - then - instead
of one one one that it would take a
series of days to make a clutch well
let's examine it so how many days would
it take for an over Raptor to lay a
clutch of 24 to 30 eggs well the two
eggs a day that's going to be 12 to 15
days well that's about the same time as
it as you as you might imagine for some
birds what's fascinating is that the
maximum clutch size for many birds
especially birds that don't take care of
their young like ducks or chickens and
their relatives is about 12 to 15 days
so it may be that even the clutch size
itself is determined by the same
ecological determinant well what that be
well I've current I've called that the
shelf-life hypothesis and that is that
the amount of time that it takes to make
a clutch it the maximum amount of time
it takes lay a clutch is the time it you
have to go before the first egg starts
to rot right because what happens they
the female will lay all those eggs and
then she sits on them and begins the
incubation well it turns out that if we
look at birds and a dinosaur's theropod
dinosaurs they might have I got the same
shelf life for an egg about 12 to 15
days and interestingly some support for
the for the shelf-life hypothesis comes
from the fact that the largest clutches
are in eggs and all bird in all birds
come from birds that live near the
Arctic Circle if you live in a
refrigerator the clock that the shelf
life should be a lot longer right so so
this is a way in which our examination
of a theropod biology is suddenly
informing ways in which
the ecological factors modern birds
might be determined
well excitingly again here's 2005 the
discoveries keep coming and coming we've
been talking about this for a couple
years and then all of a sudden comes
this this is last spring it was actually
in the middle of one anthology course
and believe it or not the Yale
undergrads read nature before the
professors can get to it and they say oh
did you see that paper and in the paper
is a pair of shelled eggs inside a
female dinosaur so this is a fossil of a
true adopted dinosaur with two eggs that
are about to be laid so it's a fossil of
exactly this this this proposed behavior
occurring so there's now a support for
the notion that this unique aspect of
bird biology actually originated back in
theropod dinosaurs so that's a way in
which the theropod original bird changes
our view of bird biology things we
thought were unique to birds are not
unique to birds well let's look at some
other things that just finish up with
how theropod original bird changes our
view of dinosaur biology well one thing
we can say is that feathers are
complicated in their color patterns this
is something we've been working on in my
lab explicitly imagine all those
different those different stripes and
dots and spots well you know it's
possible that the bird the dinosaurs
were a lot more colorful than we
imagined right if if they there's
nothing that that indicates that they
had to be drab or not colorful there's
everything to indicate that that
ornamentation of all very early on in
the history of feathers so that we could
imagine brightly striped patched spotted
theropods so this is a one case where I
think the imagination of toymakers is
not yet up to the reality all right
another thing that that we want to this
one how we're talking about bird biology
aspects of our biology that inform
dinosaur biology in my own lab we're
working on structural color but we're
also working on the vision the evolution
of avian vision so look at all these
colorful different birds and how they
how they use color well why do they have
such colors one of the things that they
they're interested in they have color
vision we this is an example of the
visible spectrum from blue all the way
to red but interestingly this is our
these are the size of the
electromagnetic waves that produce the
the light that we perceive as
color but Birds turns out there should
be another whole quadrant over here
because birds can see into the
ultraviolet way beyond human vision down
to about 350 325 nanometers so they see
colors ultraviolet colors that we cannot
see well how does that mean what how do
birds actually see colors well human
vision is based on three different cone
types one is sensitive to red green and
blue and we can imagine the the colors
as a tri-chromatic plot a stimulation of
a relative stimulation of red green and
blue cones in the retina if they we
stimulate entirely the red cones we're
going to see a red color if we stimulate
just the green we're going to see a
green color but if we mix them all
together in equal quantities will see
white which we plot here in the center
of the triangle a turquoise would be
half green and half blue a yellow would
be a mixture of green and red and and
more red would produce orange so this is
the way in which we can imagine the
human color world our trichromatic color
world but birds actually see ultraviolet
and their color space the hue the
dimensions of hues actually has an
additional dimension in addition to our
color space which imagine the bottom of
this triangle they see all sorts of
other colors including pure ultraviolet
they have other colors like ultra blue
and ultra green and ultra red or ultra
purple which I call ultra Europol who I
you know yellow plus UV all these weird
colors well did the birds actually have
these columns do they see them what do
they how do they use them well it turns
out that now that we look for these
colors in nature we find that all the
birds have them and I'm doing research
with an undergrad and that right now on
passerine of buntings here's a colorful
group of birds and I just want to focus
in on one of them the painted bunting
which is a common bird of of
southeastern United States and working
with Cassie Stoddard who's a sophomore
and what we've done is to measure the
colors of various patches on the body so
here's an example of the reflectance
spectra of the green back the blue head
and the red belly and what we could see
if each of these patches have extensive
ultraviolet in them so if we look at the
blue head right here that blue that
large line is 400 nanometers so at least
half of the reflectance off the head is
in the ultraviolet which the birds can
see but we cannot this red
and greenback or both combined with
ultraviolet Peaks so those aren't just
regular greens those are greens plus UV
it's a whole new color well what do they
look like
well Cassie's been doing some
programming to show where these colors
and the birds are found in the
trichromatic space and in this
tetrachromatic space what you can see is
to us that crown color is sort of a
royal blue but to the birds
it's a entirely different color very far
from the base of the triangle it's way
up here it has extensive ultraviolet in
it right and there's also some this rump
color which is a which is a bizarre red
plus ultraviolet or green plus
ultraviolet is also a color so so this
is an example of how the bird color
vision or color space is different from
ours and we can imagine that the colors
we see are merely a plane at but the but
the the colors in the plumage of a bird
form a volume so ultraviolet vision is
not just beyond blue it's actually an
additional dimension to color that adds
a richness to - to bird vision that that
we really can't imagine one of the key
features that we can if you think about
you can see that birds can tell who's
wearing sunscreen as the as a as a goal
you know goes over the hovers over the
beach they can tell who's wearing
sunscreen by the reflection of this game
because they can see the lack or the
presence of ultraviolet reflection right
well though I want to conclude today
with extreme dinosaur biology and this
is to help you imagine or simulate your
imagination on what birds are what what
dinosaurs might really do well in my lab
we're studying the evolution of all
sorts of courtship displays and display
behaviors interesting because it it only
has to function in the brain of the
other individuals so it's unconstrained
doesn't have to function in the real
world like a hand that might open a jar
or a beak that might crack a nut so we
see is incredible variation so here for
example some greed behaviors the wild
displays of of a frigate bird or of a
sage-grouse but in my lab we're working
on some behaviors in South American
birds in particular birds that make
sounds with their feathers oh yeah
here's another one this is a bizarre
bird this is the the Auklet that makes a
tangerine smelling it's actually the
identical organic molecule to tangerine
and they use it as a pheromone they
communicate with it
and so they preen each other remembers
the pair of preen each other and cover
each other with this tangerine pheromone
during nesting anybody seen the march of
the Penguins just imagine that much of
the Penguins with like a tangerine odor
and this is kind of what you're what you
got here but we're working on these
mannequins which are making snapping
noises we turn down the lights a little
further
whoa you see that see that this guy's
making that snapping sound by by
knocking his wings together that butter
is a wing sound he goes Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam
this is a videotape taken at 500 frames
a second in the wild in in Costa Rica so
these are birds that are making totally
unworldly different kinds of sounds with
feathers well here's the most extreme
this is the club wing mannequin from
Ecuador we hear that I'm sorry
well that's a really weird sound right
it's actually a violin sounding
electronic music you know a lot of
things you can use try to figure out
what well it took us about 20 years to
figure this out but my student Kim Bosco
finally convinced me using high-speed
video taken in Ecuador that this bird is
make not only making a sound with the
feathers but it's doing it by
stridulation it's doing it like like a
cricket makes a sound it turns out that
the feathers oscillate at about a
thousand or a hundred times a second and
that the individual feathers rub next to
each other one feather has it has a pick
and the other feather has a comb so just
like running your finger down the comb
it multiplies the frequency of the
oscillation into the frequency of the
sound so the sound is about 1,400 Hertz
and they're they're they're oscillating
at about a thousand or 100 cycles per
second so it's a it's a mechanical sound
made with feathers that entirely
converged on crickets now I want to
conclude with two videos from work of my
student ed schools who work in New
Guinea on birds of paradise here's a
bird of paradise a courtship display the
male has this sort of tutu of black
feathers these six feathers coming out
its crown and then these iridescent
structurally coloured feathers on the
throat and the blue eyes like that
to me there's nothing about what we know
about avian biology or dinosaur biology
it doesn't include the possibility of
such behaviors in other theropods right
here's another one this is another bird
of paradise with extraordinary blue
structural color plumage on the throat
and a few dots about the eyes and he's
going to make a sari
you're going to see blue here in a
second the female is going to visit in a
moment there's the color above the eyes
don't worry you haven't seen anything
yet here she comes
right now that's extreme dinosaur
biology I think you'll all agree now
he's frozen he's just breathing here for
a couple for you can see him breathing
he's just frozen in that position right
now that's an example of the extreme use
of feathers right you got optics the
structural color you have these
beautiful velvety feathers that are made
not to reflect anything you've got the
special little muscles that erect those
feathers into the other so this is not
make makes that some of those scenes in
Jurassic Park look tame right and the
fact is there's nothing about dunce or
biology or bird biology that wouldn't
indicate that this is possible so so I
hope that today I've simulated to you to
think a couple of things one that that
birds are now wholly integrated into
dinosaurs and that bird watchers are
extent dinosaur watchers there's nothing
about bird biology that isn't informed
by the knowledge that birds are living
dinosaurs today right this has both
changed our our definition of birds and
indeed our appreciation of dinosaur
biology in a new and revolutionary way
and it's it's my sincere hope that
ornithology of the next century is
basically pioneering this integration of
ornithol bird biology with dinosaur
biology and then lastly I hope that
we'll all live long enough to see the
special Jurassic Park integument airily
correct edition where you put in that
DVD and you pick a special sample that
says appropriate skin right and that we
see that whole thing again but with the
right feathers on the right organisms
because the biology of some of our
favorite dinosaurs is totally is totally
revolutionized by the fact that they
were covered with feathers and that will
truly integrates what we know about the
most extreme dinosaurs on the planet
with those that we thought we knew very
well thank you very much I'll be glad to
answer any questions
you